good morning it's tuesday today's video
is like the hair of chris hemsworth it
comes to you in three parts
part one groundbreaking hank next week
partners in health and the sierra
leonean government will
officially break ground on the maternal
center of excellence and expansion of
koidu government hospital that will be a
huge
step forward in sierra leone's fight to
radically reduce maternal mortality
despite all the challenges of the last
15 months the maternal center of
excellence is on schedule thanks to
incredibly hard work by the ministry of
health by our friends and colleagues at
pih and also thanks to the thousands of
you who've donated hank when the
pandemic first hit i assumed the mcoe
would be put off for months or perhaps
years but what happened instead is that
every month donations continued to grow
and now together with partners in health
we have raised over 20
million dollars which is it's just
overwhelming
you're seeing here where it will be and
now what it will look like
this will dramatically change the
quality of care available to women and
children
in a region where one out of every 20
women can expect to die
in childbirth this is a huge deal and
the change is already happening like
just in the last year neonatal mortality
at coitu government hospital has fallen
by
50 percent thanks to a new infant care
unit i really recommend reading pih
sierra leone's annual report link below
where they talk about this infant care
center and also
one baby nephtol whose parents as thanks
for his survival named him after his
doctor
the mental health clinic is growing as
is a new clinic for adolescent care and
the mcoe should
dramatically accelerate this progress
and because it will serve as a teaching
hospital it will train the next
generation of sierra leonean healthcare
workers
there is a very long way to go when it
comes to strengthening the healthcare
system
in sierra leone but this is a big
milestone and we are going to celebrate
it on april 29th at 6 pm eastern time
with a live stream featuring many of our
friends from pihc sierra leone i hope
you can join us
so many people have worked so hard and
been so generous to get to this moment
thank you thank you thank you i'm going
to be doing a live stream later this
afternoon to go through the financial
fundraising side of things in detail if
you're interested in that but there is
still a funding gap so if you are able
to donate to this
project please do pih.org hank and john
part two audiobooks hank i just finished
recording the audiobook for the
anthropocene reviewed which was fun and
i only came across one typo which is you
know infinitely worse than none but
twice as good as two here are some
questions i have recently received about
the book and audio book number one will
there be music
not very much of it it will mostly just
be my voice playing its only note
two will the audiobook be signed no i
have not yet figured out a way to
autograph
sound waves but i am working on it but
every pre-order of the hardcover us and
canadian edition will be signed and
there will be some signed copies
available in the uk at bookstores and
if you can find a way to order the us
edition abroad i think it will be signed
but i can't promise because of the
complexity of international copyright
and shipping and stuff
three are you going on tour yes
virtually
but there will be a tour and we will
review the anthropocene together and
there will be great special guests and
we will talk about love and loss and how
it feels to be alive in this weird
moment and it's a good opportunity to
support independent bookstores
and i will announce the tour dates when
i have them either this week or next the
book and the audiobook come out on may
18th and are available for pre-order now
okay part three nerdfighteria is amazing
and not only because you've been the
driving force behind raising over 20
million dollars to help build and
maintain a maternal and infant care
center at coitu government hospital but
also because of the stuff you'll make
all the time
like just this week on the nerdfighter
subreddit i discovered this
representation of my positive self-talk
as a poem
and also alexander daly's excellent
website linked below that sends you to a
random vlogbrothers video out of the
we have so far uploaded clicking it a
few times has taken me back to some
lovely memories as it says on my 2021
vision board hank what a long strange
trip it's been
here's to much much more i will see you
on friday